For everyone who's been waiting...
...for the return of the best new show of the year,...
...the wait is almost over!
We're glitterati. I feel like Lady Gaga.
We are gonna rule this school!
Somewhere in the English countryside, in a stately manor home,...
...Madonna is weeping!
It's an all new semester of Will versus Sue.
Let's bury the hatchet.
No, no, no, I will not be burying any hatchets...
...not unless I get a clear shot to your groin.
Cool versus gleeks.
Did you see what Rachel was wearing today?
She looked like Pippi Longstocking.
The sweaters make her look homeschooled.
And every note in between.
It's gonna be magical.
TV's best comedy returns.
All new Glee,...
...Tuesdays this April on Fox.
Your new look is...
Fantastic. Yeah, I agree.